A wise person once told me: laci, you gotta
fake it till you make it. It wasn't until
I got a little older that I realized that
was wrong. So, so very wrong.
[MUSIC]
Hey everyone, Laci Green here with a DNews
update! The data is in: Harvard scientists
have found that women who fake orgasms are
more likely to have cheated on past partners.
My first thought: BUT SO MANY WOMEN FAKE IT.
Every woman I know has faked it at least once.
A study out of the UK put the number at 80%
- 80% of women fake it at least half the time.
For men, the number is closer to 20%. It's
also true that a good chunk of people cheat
- approximately 1 in 5. To understand the
possible connection between faking orgasm
and cheating, first we gotta take a closer
look at why faking orgasm is so common.
There are lots of reasons someone might fake
an orgasm. The most common, it seems, is that
they don't want to hurt their partner's feelings
by saying.....yeahhhhhh this really isn't
doing it for me. Often times people mistakenly
believe that penetration is supposed to bring
about orgasm, when only a small proportion
of women have orgasms that way. They might
also be bored. Or tired and ready to wrap
it up. Ultimately, faking orgasm or pleasure
is about poor communication - the inability
to say "that doesn't feel good, I'm tired,
I'm bored" or whatever. Which is bad news
because faking it ends up communicating the
WRONG THINGS. It says "yeah that feels good,
I enjoy that" when it actually means the opposite.
And worse, their partner has no way to know.
So what about the study's connection to cheating?
Correlation isn't causation of course, but
I have a few ideas about why these two might
be related. Faking orgasms and cheating in
relationships can actually be caused by the
same things. Both can arise out of dissatisfaction,
feeling bored, not wanting to hurt feelings,
opting to keep up a performance rather than
have the challenging or awkward conversations
that need to be had about how things are going.
And, this non-communicative approach can of
course be bad sexually, romantically, emotionally,
and wreck havoc on sex lives and relationships.
I think that the root of this all -- bad communication
-- is common in sex and relationships because
we really don't have many conversations about
what that sort of communication looks like.
It's cloaked in awkwardness and discomfort,
shame, concern about hurt feelings, confused
emotions -- many people lack the language
to effectively say what they're feeling. It's
a symptom of a much bigger issue in how we
approach sexuality in the West. That's my
analysis, anyway. What do you guys think?
Share your thoughts and stories down below
and we'll catch you next time with more DNews!